Thomas Müller. Thomas T.H.T.H.O.M.A.S.
Mit T, genau, richtig, ganz genau.
Müller M.U.Double L.E.R.
Stimmt.
Permüller, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 54 Jahre alt.
Wie alt sind Sie, Genavje Borun?
Ich bin am 7.07.1968 geboren.
Wie schwer und wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 70 Kilogramm und ich bin ungefähr 172 groß.
75 groß?
Ja, ja.
Okay. Was für Bischoferden haben Sie?
Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen, Permüller?
Also, Sie müssten mir helfen, weil ich bin seit fünf Tagen, habe ich Herzrasen.
Und ich kriege manchmal schlecht Luft, wenn ich arbeite.
Okay.
Bistet Herzrasen dauerhaft oder kommt und geht wieder weg?
Also, ich, normalerweise habe ich nicht so einen hohen Puls.
Aber momentan, auch wenn ich in Ruhe bin, morgens aufstehe, der ist hoch.
Ich spüre den Puls hier am einem Hals.
Da spüre ich den.
Und ich weiß nicht, ich bin sehr beruhigt.
Was kann das sein?
Okay, ich verstehe Sie.
Ich muss erst mal ein paar Fragen so in der Bischwerden fragen.
Dann werde ich Sie untersuchen.
Okay. Und Sie haben auch, wenn Sie haben auch Atemnot.
Seit fünf Tagen haben Sie auch Atemnot?
Ja, seit fünf Tagen für mehr zunehmen.
Also, das hatte ich vorher gar nicht.
Das kenne ich gar nicht.
Okay.
Und Sie haben auch eine Brust oder eine Engelbegründung?
Ja, so ein bisschen.
Wenn ich arbeite, wenn ich die Treppen zu Hause hochlaufe,
dann habe ich als wenn es ein bisschen eng ist.
Ich verstehe.
Und Sie haben auch eine Brust oder eine andere Körperbegründung?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Aber manchmal ist es auch wie Rückenschmerzen.
Also, ich weiß nicht, was von der Brust kommt oder von Rücken kommt.
Und es ist irgendwie komisch.
Vielleicht habe ich eine Mannschaft vor, weil ich weiß es nicht.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Und Sie haben auch eine Brust seit fünf Tagen?
Ich verstehe.
Ja, ungefähr so eine Brust.
Und haben Sie eine Brust nur bei Belastung oder im Ruhszustand auch?
Nein, nur wenn ich mich ein bisschen bewege tatsächlich.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Ich denke, dass es mehrwürdig ist.
Ich bin sehr beunruhigt.
Okay.
Konten Sie bitte, die Schmerzen, Genalbe Schreiben,
sind die Schmerzen, Dumf, drückend, sternd?
Nein, das sind keine sternden Schmerzen.
Das ist so ein...
Ja, das drückt ein bisschen.
Der Brust am Rücken so ein bisschen eher.
Der Brust ist eher so drückend.
Aber in Ruh habe ich keine...
Aber das ist gar nicht das Problem.
Das Herzrasen, das Herz ist schnell unterwegs.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Aber diese Brustschmerzen sind auch für uns sehr wichtig.
Und deswegen frage ich.
Okay.
Und haben Sie etwas dagegen eingenommen, Medikamente oder andere?
Nein, ich nehme die üblichen Medikamente wie vorher ein.
Nein.
Okay.
Waren Sie deswegen bei einem Arzt oder Hausarzt?
Nein, leider nicht.
Ich habe keine Zeit gehabt.
Ich bin in meiner Arbeit und ich schaffe das nicht.
Okay.
Und besteht das Herzrasen gleichzeitig mit Brustschmerzen oder...
Was sehen Sie?
Nein, das ist unabhängig.
Das ist unabhängig davon.
Das ist die ganze Zeit.
Die ganze Zeit ist es schnell unterwegs.
Und wenn ich mich bewege, wenn ich schnell laufe,
dann merke ich das richtig.
Dann pocht das ja richtig.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Haben Sie Ihre Herzfrequenz zuhause gemessen und Blutdruck?
Also der Blutdruck ist eher niedrig, muss man sagen.
Der ist ungefähr bei 100, 110, ungefähr der obere Wert.
Und die Herzfrequenz ist tatsächlich über 90.
90 bis 100, ja.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Aber ich verstehe nicht, warum der Blutdruck so niedrig ist.
Woran kann das liegen?
Okay, ich untersuche Ihre Herzfrequenz
und Ihre Blutdruck messe ich noch mal.
Und dann werde ich...
Mein Vater ist ein Herzinfarkter, der Storben.
Kann das Herzinfarkt sein?
Kann ich einen Herzinfarkt haben?
Ja, wir hoffen momentan, dass das nicht schlimm ist.
Aber ich werde alle Untersuchungen machen.
Ja, wir gucken mal, okay?
Wir müssen erst mal die Untersuchungen machen.
Ja, weil mein Vater, den haben die auch nicht schnell behandelt
und dann ist er gestorben.
Der war der lange auf Intensivstation und so was.
Okay, das tut mir sehr leid.
Aber wie gesagt, ich werde auch Ihr Herz untersuchen, okay?
Machen Sie momentan keine Sorge.
Sie sind in guten Händen.
Und Sie haben auch Atemnot und haben Sie Fieber?
Nein.
Okay.
Haben Sie interlesse desert gebigte, ab oder sugenoven?
Nein, immer gleich. Ich bin immer schon 70 kg.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Hatten Sie früher eine Hebäche verdammt?
Nein.
Wie früher, Herzrausen oder Brustschimmersen?
Nein, das ist das erste Mal.
Das erste Mal.
Okay, waren Sie interlesse desert im Ausland?
Ich war vor kurzem in Spanien.
Wann war das?
Das war vor zwei Wochen.
Vor zwei Wochen.
Hat jemand in der Familie eine Hebäche verdammt?
Oder nur bei Ihnen?
Nein.
Ich habe keine Familie.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Was ist normalerweise in Portugal?
Ich fahre viel Fahrrad, normalerweise.
Aber in den letzten drei Wochen nicht mehr.
Seit dem Urlaub habe ich nichts gemacht.
Ich habe keine Zeit gehabt.
Aber davor fahre ich normalerweise regelmäßig Fahrrad.
Ich verstehe.
Ich glaube, dass es vom Herzen kommt.
Glauben Sie auch, dass es vom Herzen kommt?
Das ist so für etwas genauser zu sagen.
Aber ich werde auch Ihr Herz unterzuholen.
Okay?
Ja.
Okay.
Sie wissen, dass es sehr viel ist?
Nein.
Haben Sie Schwellung im Haspera bemerkt?
Mein Nachbar hat auch die Stand bekommen letzte Woche.
Ich habe echt Angst.
Ja, ich verstehe Ihre Angst.
Aber wie gesagt, wir gucken mal nach auch Ihren Herz,
auch alle Kritikssachen.
Okay, Sie sind in guten Händen.
Man hat gar keine Sorge.
Wenn etwas passiert, können Sie einfach bei uns melden.
Und wir können einfach eingreifen.
Seit 27 Jahren schon Astens-Ärzten.
Ist das in Ihrem Fachbereich?
Nein.
Kennen Sie sich den Herz aus?
Ja, natürlich.
Aber wir arbeiten als Team.
Ich werde mit meinem Oberarzt-Syprien über ihre Bischöfe.
Okay?
Ja, kann ich die auch gleich sehen?
Oder habe ich nur mit Ihnen Kontakt?
Nach der Runtersun können Sie auch mit dem Oberarzt-Syprien.
Okay, alles klar.
Ich muss erst mal alle Fragen stellen, okay?
Gerne.
Ist Ihnen Bein-Schwellung aufgefallen?
Nein.
Nein, ich habe tatsächlich ein Ziehen in der rechten Wade.
Ziehen, rechten Wade.
Aber ich glaube, ich habe mich...
Ich glaube, ich habe mich schon nach dem Urlaub aufgefallen.
Ich habe da viel geschwommen.
Ich glaube, ich habe mir etwas gezerrt oder so.
Das zieht so ein bisschen.
Okay, aber haben Sie keine Schwellung im Beinen?
Hab ich nicht gemerkt, aber das zieht schon so ein bisschen.
Nur rechte Seite.
Rechte Seite, ja.
Ist das rechte Bein überwärmt oder gerötet?
Nein.
Gar nicht.
Pusten Sie?
Nein.
Und vor der Wahlwoche sind Sie zurückgekommen, stimmt?
Richtig, ganz genau, vor zwei Wochen.
Mit Flugzeug oder...
Ich war zwei Wochen...
Mit Flugzeug.
Okay, wie lange hat Flugreise gedauert?
Ungefähr drei Stunden ungefähr.
Okay, verstehe.
Und haben Sie noch andere Bechwärten?
Übelkeit, Erbrechen...
Das bin ich auch gefallen. Nein, das bin ich auch gefallen.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Massalasen oder so?
Nein.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft, Corona auch?
Ja, ich bin vollständig geimpft.
Drei Mal.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Aber Sie machen auch eine EKG gleich, oder?
Ja, natürlich.
Ich werde auch EKG schreiben.
Dann können wir Ihre Aktivität ganz gut beurteilen.
Ich werde auch Blut abnehmen, okay?
Okay.
Und Herr Müller, haben Sie irgendwelche chronische Erkrankungen?
Ich meine, Asthma, Bluthoffdruck oder andere...
Nein, aber ich nehme Medikamente hin.
Und zwar einmal für meinen erhöhten Erkrankungen.
Ich habe erhöhte Haarsäure.
Und ich habe auch erhöhte Cholesterolwerke, sagt meine Arzt mir.
Und deswegen nehme ich seit ungefähr 3 Jahren ein Cholesterolmedikament.
Und wie geht es Ihnen?
Ich habe eine Medikamente.
Nein, das ist in einem Jahr ungefähr.
Okay.
Und wer ist derjenige, der sich mit dem Medikament verwendet?
Ich habe einen Medikament.
Also, okay.
Und wer ist derjenige, der sich mit dem Medikament verwendet?
Also, ich nehme einmal Atobastatin, 40 Milligramm, ein Abend.
Und einmal Alloporinol, 100 Milligramm morgens.
Okay.
Und wer ist derjenige, der sich mit dem Medikament verwendet?
Nicht bekannt.
Okay.
Und wer ist derjenige, der sich mit dem Medikament verwendet?
Ja, Ibuprofen oder so.
Ibuprofen oder so.
Ibuprofen, Ibuprofen oder so.
Ich habe oft Kopfschmerzen auch, aber das ist jetzt egal eigentlich.
Ich habe mehr private Problemen.
Okay. Leiden Sie unter Stärkestress?
Natürlich.
Ich bin Elektriker immer am arbeiten.
Immer, immer am arbeiten.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Ich habe mich scheiden lassen.
Und zwei Kinder noch.
Aber alles schwierig.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Das ist sehr schwierig für Sie.
Aber ich glaube, das hat nichts damit zu tun in meinem Herzrasen.
Aber ich glaube, das hat nichts mit meinem Herzrasen zu tun, glaube ich, diese Frage.
Nein, Stress ist sehr wichtig für Ihre Beschwerden.
Das kann auch ein Risikofaktor für Herzerkrankungen sein.
Okay.
Ich muss alle Risikofaktoren fragen, okay?
Wurdens ist schon mal operiert?
Nein.
Doch am Knie.
Von vorn?
Das war irgendwie als Miniskusoperation.
Vilanga ist das?
20 Jahre ungefähr.
Für Zivansisjaren.
Verzeihzeit?
Rechts.
Habt ihr es allerginen, Müller?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Okay, rauchen Sie?
Ja.
Seit wann und wie viel Zigaretten rauchen Sie?
Ich weiss nicht. Ich rauche eine Packung am Tag.
Seit etwa 15 Jahren ungefähr.
Also ungefähr 40 Jahre seit?
Ja, bestimmt.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, am Wochenende.
Was trinken und wie viel Alkohol trinken Sie?
Hauptsächlich Bier.
Aber mein Arzt sagt, ich soll jetzt aufhören,
weil die Haare so etwas brauchen.
Stimmt.
Und wie viel trinken Sie?
Das weiss ich nicht.
Wir sind in der Kneipe und keine Ahnung.
Am Wochenende trinken wir es.
Also, meine sehr viel?
Ja, für mich ist es nicht viel, aber mein Arzt sagt, das wäre viel.
Okay, können Sie einschätzen, wie viel Flasche?
Keine Ahnung, 6, 7, 8 ungefähr.
Aber nur am Wochenende, in der Woche darf ich dich, ich muss arbeiten.
Ich muss Geld verdienen.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Und, Herr Müller, haben Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Das ist eine Routine Frage, ich muss sich stellen.
Sie haben schon erwähnt, Sie arbeiten als Elektriker.
Ich bin Elektriker, ja, ich bin Elektriker, genau.
Okay, sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin geschieden, habe ich gerade gesagt.
Ja, stimmt.
Und Sie haben Tochter?
Ich habe 2 Söhne.
Söhne, okay, schuldigung.
Sind Sie gesund?
Ich?
Nein, Söhne, die Söhne.
Ja, Riesengesot, ja.
Okay.
Und Sie haben schon erwähnt, die Fatah ist an Herzinfarkt verstorben.
Genau, für fünf Jahre.
Für fünf Jahre.
Mitwärtschem Ayrta ist verstorben.
Der war ungefähr 75.
Lebt ihr ihr Mutha, ne?
Die lebt noch, ja.
Hat sie irgendwann chairkranken?
Ich glaube, ihr habt Zucker, ich weiß gar nicht.
Ich habe jetzt nicht so viel Kontakt zu ihr.
Ja, okay.
Und haben Sie Geschwister?
Ja, aber auch nicht viel Kontakt.
Wie viele Geschwister haben Sie?
2 Schwestern.
Okay, verstehe.
Und Sie haben noch eine Frage, so ihr aktuellen Beschi verdankt.
Können Sie flachlegen?
Also brauchen Sie viele Kiste zum Schlafen?
Nein, ich kann normal liegen.
Ich bin aber eher so ein Seitenschlefer, deswegen brauche ich Kommkissen.
Ich schlafe immer auf meinem Arm drauf.
Okay, verstehe.
Und haben Sie Probleme beim Schlafen?
Ein oder durchschlafen?
In den letzten fünf Tagen schon, weil ich meine Herz spüre, sonst nicht.
Okay, verstehe.
Können wir jetzt langsam das EKG machen oder dauert das noch lange?
Ich habe alle wichtige Fragen gestartet.
Momentan werde ich Sie unterzuholen.
Ihr Herzfrekans und Atemfrekans.
Was glaubt ihr denn, was schaue?
Kann das das Herz sein?
Das ist eine Möglichkeit, aber ich kann nicht genau sagen.
Ich muss erst mal die Unterzuhlungsergebnisse abwarten.
Dann kann ich über Ihre Beschi werden mit Ihnen noch mal schieben.
Aber es kann ja nur das Herz sein.
Es kann ja nichts anderes sein.
Aber man macht das genauso.
Ja, ich verstehe, das kommt von Herzen.
Aber das ist so, wie gesagt, etwas genau sagen.
Ich brauche Unterzuhlungen.
Aber Sie müssen nur ein EKG machen oder nicht?
Oder was ist denn zu früh?
Ich mache sofort eine EKG.
Und ich werde auch Blutabnehmen, Blutergebnisse auch sehr wichtig für uns.
Für Ihre Beschiwerden-Abklärung.
Und ich werde auch Röntgenaufnahme von Lungen fernlassen.
Und nach dem Ergebnis von Foreleague
werde ich mit Ihnen noch mal schieben.
Das ist das
Vorliegen.
Nicht, dass es zu spät ist.
Bei meinem Vater haben Sie auch nicht gut gearbeitet.
Und das hat dann weiter auf Intensivstationen.
Und dann ist sie verstorben danach.
Ja, machen Sie keine Sorge.
Ich mache mir Sorge.
Ich habe ja Beschwerden.
Ich muss mir Sorge machen.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Aber Sie sind in guten Händen.
Sie sind im Krankenhaus.
Wir sind für Sie immer da.
Und eine Schwester bleibt mit Ihnen immer da.
Sie können einfach anmelden.
Wenn etwas passiert, können Sie einfach eingreifen.
Ja, ich hoffe.
Bitte nehmen Sie Pilaz unter die Suchungsschrift.
Danke schön.
Hallo.
Guten Tag.
Ich bin der Assistentin der Stintätik.
Ich habe eine neue Patientin vorgestellt.
Sie sind in der Lage.
Okay.
Ich habe eine Meta-75-Groß.
Peace.
Ich habe eine Meta-75-Groß Danke.
Ich habe eine Meta-75-Groß.
Ich bin als HolymächtJun以及 die fiveriere
ich habe eine Meta-75-Groß.
Und ich habe eine Meta-75-Groß Robotin erzählt.
Ich will versuchen,
Und ausserdem erwähnte der Patient, dass er vor Zybaldwogen aus Spanien zurückgekommen ist.
Und seitdem hat er auch sehende Schmerzen oder Spaniengefühl in Rechten wahren.
Und frage nach Emesis, Emesis, Nozja, Fiba, Gewissölferenderungen, Husten, Beinödeme, Wurdenferneint,
Der Patient hat auch gelegentlich Kopfschmerzen.
Dagegen nimmt er bei Bedarf Schmerzmittel ein.
Er treibt regelmäßig Sport, aber seit ungefähr 2-3 Wochen kann er nicht regelmäßig Sport treiben.
Er leitet ein Ertreites-Ürka-Unt-Hyperlipidemi.
Er nimmt ein Atorvastatin für 40 mg einmal abends.
Er nimmt alle Pyrrhenol ein 100 mg einmal morgens ein.
Bei Bedarf nimmt er Ibuprofen ein.
Bei ihm wurde für die Sivansicht year ne Menuschiesoperation am rechten Knie durchefür.
Bei ihm ist keine Alergie bekannt.
Er ruft seit vier Jahren den einen Sivansicht-Sigaret des erschöp чего für sivansichtspakung Jest.
Er trinkt sieben, acht Fleischabier, an Wohnen, fragt nach Drogengurde fernrein,
er ist elektrika, er ist geschieden, hat sivaisone, die gesund sind.
Die Familie ist für die 5 Jahre, also die 5,7 Jahre, am Yokart, in Farkfärschturben.
Die Mutter leidet an die Bethesmellitus, er hat Sivaisgechiris,
aber hat keinen Kontakt zu ihnen. Er ist vollständig geimpft.
Also, alle anderen, die sich in Angaben durch den Aufwachen haben,
sind pulmenarembolin, als differenzial diaknosokomun miokartinfarkt,
pünomotorax, artunanevrisma, instabilangina pectoris, imbetracht.
Meine Verdacht diaknosobestätigen,
werde ich zuerst die Patientenkörperreche unterzuholen.
Diese Patienten sollten auch stationär aufgenommen werden.
Ich werde Vitalparameter messen und den Patienten an Monito anschließen.
Ich werde sofort eine EKG schreiben und Blutabnehmen.
Ich werde Blutbild, Einstündungsparameter, Troponin,
Stekasek-KMB bestimmen.
Bei dieser Patient ist auch Röntgen Aufnahmefondungen wichtig.
Ich werde Röntgen Torax zwajebenen,
in zwajebenen fernlassen.
Und gegen meine Fazit kann Angiografie erfolgen.
Bei dieser Patientin.
Jetzt haben Sie ganz viele Untersuchungen genannt.
Also, Sie haben das gut gemacht für mich.
Wir haben eine gute Differenzialdiagnose gestellt.
Jetzt scheint der Patient schon längere,
bei ein paar Tagen vermehrt Luftnot zu haben.
Diesen Patienten müssen Sie natürlich notfallmäßig versorgen.
Bevor Sie zu mir kommen,
müssen Sie eine Monito anschließen.
direkt eine Monito anschließen.
Ich werde Sie nicht sofort in EKG-Scheiben,
um zu sehen, wie gut es oder wie schlecht es den Patienten geht.
Die Untersuchungen, die Sie genannt haben, sind alle möglich.
Aber ich denke, wir sollten vielleicht auch übersprechen,
was Sie als Erstes machen.
Welche Untersuchungen Sie weglassen können.
Wenn Sie den Verdacht haben,
auf eine Lungenarterie in der Embolie,
dann können Sie die gleichen Schritte anschließen.
Sie messen die Vitalparameter,
Sie machen einen EKG,
und Sie schließen den Patient an den Monitor an.
Was Sie jetzt am EKG sehen können,
ob er zum Beispiel einen Stemi hat,
einen STI Elevationsinfarkt hat,
oder nicht.
Dann können Sie vielleicht erst meinen Herzinfarkt ausschließen.
Dann können Sie sehen,
ob er über 100 oder über 120 ist.
Sie können sehen, ob er einen Vorrufflimmern hat.
Vielleicht macht ihm das Vorrufflimmern die Beschwerden.
Ihre Verdachtdiagnose mit Lungenarterie in der Embolie teile ich.
Ich denke, dass er eine Lungenarterie in der Embolie haben könnte.
Was machen Sie, wenn das EKG,
der Blutdruck einigermaßen in Ordnung ist,
und Sie haben Blutabrundung, was machen Sie als Nächstes?
Was können Sie in der Ambulanz noch machen?
Das ist eine Art Ultraschalldespans,
die ich durchführen werde.
Das brauchen Sie nicht.
Das hat keine Konsequenz.
Er hat Luftnot.
Seine Schmerzen sind ja nicht so stark im Wein.
Sie haben den Verdacht auf eine Lungenarterie in der Embolie.
Um dies vielleicht beweisen zu machen,
können Sie ein Herzultraschall machen.
Was kontrollieren Sie?
Herzultraschall kann ich bei Bewegungsteuerungen,
bei EMI sehen.
Ansonsten kann ich bei der Belastung sehen.
Ganz genau.
Wenn Sie das sehen,
dann brauchen Sie gar keine Röntgen für Wachs machen.
Dann machen Sie direkt eine CT-Angiografie.
Wenn Sie kein Ultraschall haben,
dann machen Sie den Schnelltest EDMARE.
Wenn der positiv ist,
machen Sie direkt eine Angiografie.
Ohne Echo können Sie auch machen.
Wenn der Patient stabil ist,
und er kippt gleich um,
dann geht eine CT-Angiografie.
Dann müssen Sie etwas machen,
wenn der Patient instabil ist.
Angeografie? Nein.
Wenn er instabil ist,
dann hat er eine Herzultrenz von 130
und ein Blutdruck von 80 nicht toll.
Und Luftnot.
Was machen Sie dann?
Kardiorvarsia? Nein.
Sie haben den Verdacht auf eine Lungenatherie-Embulie.
Eine fulminante Lungenatherie-Embulie.
Was müssen Sie machen,
um den Trombus aufzulösen?
Heparin, sofort Medikamentus-Therapie
oder Chirurgische Therapie.
Ich werde sofort Heparin verordnen.
Dann können Sie eine Lüse machen.
Wenn der Patient instabil ist,
kann man direkt mit einer Lüse beginnen.
Wenn Sie keinen Ultraschall haben
oder der Patient nicht warten kann
für eine CT-Angiografie,
dauert er manchmal 2 Stunden,
bis man eine CT machen kann.
Sehr gut.
Dann kann man die Lüse machen.
Dann kann man eine CT machen.
Sie haben die Differenzialdiagnosen gut dargestellt.
Was Sie machen,
müssen Sie nicht ins Wartezimmer stricken.
Sie sagen, warten Sie, ich komme gleich.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie sind in guten Händen.
Eine Schlüssel wird bei Ihnen sein.
Sie haben den Patient ruhig beruhigen können.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie müssen in guten Händen.
Sie müssen den Patient sagen,
ich werde Sie an den Monitor anschließen.
Wenn dort etwas sein sollte, werden wir sofort eingreifen.
Das haben Sie gut gelöst.
Bravo.